single single single are you know I am
plagued with the on-again off-again I'm
very single right now I'm actually
dating the law I love to meet new people
it's fun being friends with curly just
for the gossip or that she's me cuz it's
like oh my god I was with this guy
yesterday and he said this I'm like what
and oh my god remember that guy which
guy no no the other guy doesn't know
something about one's day I am in a
committed monogamous relationship it's
almost gonna be two years now we live
together we have two cats very serious I
guess everything you said was an anxiety
that was scary
oh man the cats I am just allowing two
brushes I am so single right now it is
not even funny I think it's very similar
to why I think I'm single I think that
we're picky and right insecure all
together so it's like oh no I'm too and
then like the underside you're like oh I
could never be with you I'm a little
potato but I do love to be cuddled oh oh
no okay
[Music]
we're thinking equate all take all the
things you have said and we will tell
you now single you are the first ones
Hey with a bunch of wise that is like me
to a tee yeah say that hey you that's
more reserved for like you know you know
I have been okay with one why is
concerning like there's something wrong
but a bunch a is like hey like friendly
and it's just one word it's so little
work [ __ ] too many ways I'd never say
that you would say that I always say
that I'm too busy with work right now
I'm just too busy with work right now
yeah that's true I do so many things
what if I become a crazy cat lady I've
thought about this but the thing is I
don't like cats and I'm not a lady so
what is the male equivalent I think it's
just like me playing n64 by myself why
is it so hard to find someone yes I have
said that
I'm checking off way more than I thought
it was I'm like boom boom boom I'm not
just going to settle for anyone that's
true yeah I said that I feel like I am
picky like I come home and there is no
significant other with me for the
holidays my mom just gave up on me she's
like you're just the pickiest person I
know my friends call it but but I was
telling you oh my god like I met this
guy and they'll be like okay but where's
the butt and I'm like but no you are
picky yeah I'm picky that one for me is
cuz like I feel like I've watched my
parents my hands been together for like
30 years
they went through a lot of ups and downs
and so for me I'm like oh
[Music]
okay which may be actually committing an
arrest on one I definitely said what
should I text back because I'm always
screen shouting my conversations and
sending them to my friends I just want
someone to talk to now I have a dog I
don't have a dog I just want to make me
like yeah dating is so [ __ ] it is indeed
very [ __ ] where you might meet people
these days I never write tinder where do
you meet people these days I feel like
it's very difficult I feel like
everyone's on social media I may have
dabbled in some DM I think I'm going to
stay in and maybe watch some Netflix
tonight yeah I've only said who needs
love anyway and me I need love I thought
being single was meant to be fun it is
especially if you're in your holidays
I'm no longer in my ho days but when I
was in my house
oh I've never had a le côté you just
need to run down the rack of dick for
just like hit em off you're running down
the aisles like I don't even care about
Valentine's Day I don't care about that
day I usually schedule the off again
between Thanksgiving and February oh my
god you just complete during the
holidays bears hibernate I love you and
I'm single do you do my mom sends me oh
my god I'm so lonely yes really miners
call me yes there's other things that I
need oh you mean like I'm so horny I'm
so horny check oh why are all the good
men flash women taken now they're not
clearly oh here it is these are the
results of how single we were when we
were single I feel like this is like a
teacher giving me a grade on my love
life I got 14 out of 49 that's 20%
single back when I was single which I
feel like is
accurate I'm 30% single it says you're
still enjoying the single life you're at
the point where it's all new and fun
enjoy it oh this is very mean you know
me so well I don't know if I would say
it was new and fun when I was single I
wasn't stressed about being single I
kind of just rolled with it and let the
chips fall where they did that's just
such a beautiful way to live I wish
everyone could live like Ella I think
that just comes with not having a high
sex drive
I'm sure is only gonna happen to me Oh
53% man says you're still pretty hopeful
you're dating and yes it could be [ __ ]
but it also could be really good no one
is just around the corner cool it's true
I am still hopeful I know somebody just
to make my heart happy yeah I got 30 out
of 49
I am 61% single hmm you've been single
for way too long okay it's an attack on
me cool quite frankly you're sick of
this [ __ ] you're sick of dating sick of
trying and you're just sick of it all
but it's all good keep doing you and
being great thank you do seem to think
of it I am very sick of it
yeah years and years of dating you do
get sick of this [ __ ] it's like life is
terrible
have fun wait keep doing good luck
listen up single people we are single
and we're great if you have such a
negative attitude towards love and you
we're not going to respond to the single
audience I say
gonna laugh I think that like people
need to look for love in other places
other than one person you need to look
for love and your through your best
friends or your family things that you
need to also self like or like even your
cat you know tinder Wow they true to
yourself be safe
value your needs first if you want to
holla at me definitely slide into my DMS
don't send me anything dirty because I
usually screenshot bags and it's all my
friends we're in a day and age where
it's real fun but real sad at the same
time we are in the era of options an era
of beautiful filters an era of swipes so
it could seem impossible that you'll
ever find the right one but it's like a
big ol buffet but usually buffets don't
taste that good so take your time wait
for proper me oh yes we're single you
guys really really think yeah
[Music]
oh yeah
[Laughter]